pop onto the website for feel good
subscription box firm all true and you
might think the company is still
operating as normal but there's one very
important detail the company hasn't
communicated to potential customers all
true is going out of business
build as a way to support small mostly
women-run businesses all true never
announced it was closing its virtual
doors
frustrated subscribers are still waiting
on orders they've already paid for while
vendors say they're sitting on unpaid
invoices totaling at least 1.9 million
dollars the los angeles-based company
laid off its entire staff to about 50
earlier this month according to a
linkedin post from a former employee
around the same time all true filed
paperwork to start an assignment for the
benefit of creditors a voluntary
alternative to formal bankruptcy
since these cases don't require a public
court filing in california this step can
be taken by distressed businesses
looking to minimize publicity
ceo matt richardson did not make a
public statement when the company
decided to shudder but confirmed to
forbes last week that all true is in the
process of an assignment for the benefit
of creditors
richardson said he can't comment further
but said quote the assignee hopes to
have an update soon at which point there
will be more information to share
richardson co-founded what is now all
true with his childhood friend brett
mccullum in 2014 it developed a legion
of loyal fans who joined facebook groups
dedicated to discussing selling and
trading their all true items with other
subscribers touting how much they were
helping local artisans both founders
landed on the 2019 forbes 30 under 30
social impact list they changed their
name to altru in 2021
last year the company claimed to have
more than 300 thousand subscribers each
paying anywhere between 50 to 55 dollars
per box
despite their image as promoting small
businesses according to vendors on
reddit the company hasn't been very
helpful companies expecting to be
featured in all true this year never got
paid for the products they sent leaving
at least one small business out of four
hundred thousand dollars and on the
verge of insolvency
seven brands say they are owed one
hundred thousand dollars or more
five vendors told forbes their attempts
to contact all true have been met with
silence
though these businesses can file a claim
as one of all true's creditors it
remains unclear if they will ever get a
payout or recover their products some of
which are handmade and one of a kind
forbes found 18 brands claiming they
haven't been paid by all true altogether
the vendors say they lost 170 000 units
of unpaid product from their businesses
customers too are furious
altru gave shoppers the option of paying
for a single box or they could purchase
an annual subscription of 4 boxes for
roughly 200
altru also offered additional products
as voluntary add-ons each quarter
while all true's demise seems sudden
this isn't the first time it has faced
scrutiny when it was still named
causebox the company voluntarily
recalled stainless steel kettles sent to
customers in early 2021 because they
posed a burn hazard
according to the consumer product safety
commission the company received 122
reports of the kettles releasing hot
water or excessive steam resulting in 18
minor burn injuries
at the time the company admitted to
sourcing the kettle's in-house while
sticking the name of brooklyn-based
artisan brand rose and fitzgerald on the
bottom of the kettle as part of a
licensing agreement
[Music]